this is Dirk twine and I'll be speaking
with Dr Joel Wallach the mineral doctor
Dr Wallach is considered the premier
Authority on nutrition in the United
States he has written more than a dozen
books on health and nutrition and
countless peer-reviewed papers one of
his earliest books exposed the
consequences of nutritional deficiencies
in animals and humans entitled diseases
of exotic animals and is currently in
the U.S Smithsonian Institute and has
been declared a National Treasure Dr
Wallace research and discovery of the
90th Century nutrients required for
animals and humans was groundbreaking in
the fact that 60 of the 90 nutrients or
minerals has garnered Dr Wallach the
title of the mineral doctor
thank you greetings this is dark twine
speaking with Dr Joel wallet the mineral
doc Dr Wallach and I will discuss the
vegetarian diet however before we begin
the discussion I would like Dr Wallach
to briefly share with some of the more
than 40 Years of biomedical research and
clinical medicine experience that he has
in nutrition and in health well thank
you Dirk the thing that makes me
different when it comes to being a
health practitioner is that I have a
degree in agriculture in the
agricultural industry we don't have
health insurance for animals so we
learned how to prevent reverse diseases
with nutritional formulas we've known
for over a hundred years that our food
supply for livestock and humans is
deficient so we do have to make up that
diff went on to get a degree in
veterinary medicine and then I became a
compared pathologist in one project with
the National Institutes that held the
centers for the biology of natural
systems Washington University St Louis I
actually did over 20 000 autopsies from
zoos and human beings living near the
zoo some seventeen thousand five hundred
autopsies and over 454 species of zoo
animals three thousand humans for a
comparison 10 million chemistries 10
million slides of special stains looking
for pollution primarily but also looking
for nutritional deficiencies and
actually published the first paper ever
in the United States on a mass die off
from pollution in 1962 and that just to
actually set my career off in a
particular direction that I wound up
with one paper then went to as I say
graduated veterans then became a
physician began treating patients as a
primary care physician in 1978 and so
I've got 35 years of experience in
translating animal nutrition into human
nutrition of course a lot of my patients
would have a lot of fun with it and they
say well if you're not happy with your
doctor or go see Wallach now he'll treat
you like a dog which you get better oh
that's great well thank you doc as a
vegetarian for nearly 20 years I'm very
eager to hear your perspective on
vegetarianism so so let's get started
firstly I'd like to share something that
probably most people are unaware of the
word vegetarian comes from the Latin
word vegetas which means whole energetic
and full of life it was coined in the
1840s in England so this that phrase is
being been around for quite some time
however in the U.S today it has a
slightly different meeting it seems to
have expanded since the Inception of the
philosophy and the practice let's look
at the various types of vegetarians in
the U.S first we'll start out with vegan
spelled v-e-g-a-n but pronounced vegan a
person that eats a plant-based diet
exclusively fruits vegetables nuts
grains seeds legomes or beans a lacto is
a person that eats a plant-based diet
but also includes dairy products such as
cow's milk and its byproducts cheese
yogurt sour cream
Etc oval is a person that eats a
plant-based diet also but includes eggs
from either chickens or duck or some
other type of animal Pesco is a person
that eats a plant-based diet but
includes fish and then Polo is a person
that eats the plant-based diet and also
includes chicken however the only true
vegetarian is the vegan and all others
are consuming animal flesh hence
nutritionally they are nearly the same
therefore our discussion will primarily
be about the vegan vegetarian diet I
think we will try to express the
challenges of that type of diet so doc
let's begin with the most frequently
Asked question of vegetarians can the
vegetarian diet meet all nutritional
needs particularly protein in modern
times the answer to that is no and I'm
always sad when people pay primarily
attention to protein this vegan's Mantra
oh we mix legumes and Grains together so
we get perfect protein well that's only
one of the 90 essential nutrients
they're leaving themselves under the
other 89 is that leaving out of the
other 89 to get vegans in trouble you
think about some of the more famous
vegans Linda McCartney Paul McCartney
the beetle his wife actually made more
money selling her prepared vegan meals
or in her vegan cookbook she made more
money she made billions of dollars as
opposed to The Beatles that she made
more money than they did as a singing
group and she died of 52. then you look
at Michael Jackson whose life was really
messed up and he was a vegan I look at
um Steve Jobs he was a vegan he died of
56 and so on and so veganism is
problematic and the reason is the
Assumption when you eat a vegan diet is
that everything is perfect and it's not
uh what you're doing is you're depending
on getting the all 90 essential
nutrients on the throw of a dice every
morning what if I were to prepare a game
for you Dirk and say okay let's let's
play a game let's both we're going to
agree the rest of our lives are going to
play this game you wake up in the
morning and you throw the dice and if
you get any number but Snake Eyes which
is a one on both dice you get to live
another day but if you get Snake Eyes
you shoot yourself in the head that's
not a good game yeah it's not a good
game because eventually you're gonna hit
snake eyes aren't you that's what even
though he said well I mean come on how
often is that going to happen but you're
going to wind up shooting yourself in
the head if you follow the rules of the
game the same with veganism there are
some communities around the world who
can practice veganism because of dumb
luck because they've got 60 70 minerals
in their soil and all the nutrients they
grow in the soil all the plants they
grow in the soil will suck up these
minerals they use wood for fuel their
third world cultures they use wood for
fuel and they're putting the wood ashes
which really aren't ashes which are the
the minerals are left when you burn the
tree for fuel they put that in the
garden and the trees take up those
minerals which are recycling those 60
essential minerals but we're talking
about really isolated places very few
out of 7 billion people on Earth we're
talking about maybe 200 people okay less
than four or less than one percent
obviously you know one thousandths of
one percent could eat well and get
everything they need and so we actually
began the shooter so in fact the guy who
invented McCormick farming equipment he
died in his 30s from pernicious anemia
because he was a vegan I mean he was one
of the first billionaires in America
along with the steel makers you know
Carnegie and people like that and his
name was McCormick and he died of
pernicious anemia actually took a tour
of the facility either his original plan
and they said he died of pernicious
anemia and I said well that's just a B12
deficiency and they said well yeah he
had to B12 deficiency because he was a
vegan okay okay uh I always that was a
great uh analogy that you gave but I
like to uh when I speak to people about
supplementing I like to give a car
analogy if I was leaving Atlanta Georgia
going to California and my fuel gauge
didn't work I would certainly fill up my
car on a daily basis to make sure that I
had enough fuel to make it across the
country and I think that's analogous to
what you're saying in terms of we can't
take the chance on running out of gas we
have to fuel ourselves on a daily basis
and my understanding and correct me if
you you may uh that the main reason that
we're eating food on a daily basis is to
get nutrients from that food we're not
eating for Taste we're not eating
because it's pretty we're eating because
our body requires nutrients well you're
exactly right these 90 essential
nutrients have that funny little word in
their essential these are not the 90
optional nutrients they're as
predictable as gravity you will die if
you're missing these things some of them
like a potassium if you don't have any
potassium in your diet your heart will
stop and you'll die within seconds after
being totally deficient in potassium on
the other hand if you're deficient in
calcium you might live 40 years but
you're going to have osteoporosis you'll
get fractures to get kidney stones your
teeth will fall out you get high blood
pressure you get bone spurs and calcium
deposits you'll mind with all these
weird diseases which support the
orthopedic surgeons very well thank you
um your urologists for kidney stones and
dentists for periodontal disease all of
which are simple Calcium deficiency
diseases but eventually you'll fall and
Fracture a hip and so secondary is a
secondary cause of the Calcium
deficiency will die and so
um every one of these essential
nutrients is required every day in
optimal amounts and I'm I'm 73 now Dirk
and I've been taking these 90 essential
nutrients twice a day since I was nine
years old this has nine and I've been
blessed with good health haven't been to
a doctor with me being the patient in 64
years and
um
I've never been on a prescription
medication and this is because I have
gone out of my way to supplement my food
and I eat well I eat very well because
again I have a degree in agriculture I'm
a veterinarian I'm a physician I'm a
pathologist and so I know you have to
eat well and I eat well but I don't
depend on the nutrients in the food I
just look at nutrients and the food as
value added and to me eating is more of
a social event because I supplement
twice a day with a 90 essential
nutrients I take in probably in some
cases 25
000 times a minimum day requirement you
heard that number right 25
000.25 000 times the minimum data
requirement okay and people say well how
do you keep going how can you do 300
free lectures a year and and you're
never worn out you're never angry you're
never depressed I said well it's because
they take the 90 essential nutrients
twice a day but I don't take them I
don't minimize I don't take them at the
minimum daily requirement okay for
instance selenium the minimum data
requirement according to the government
is 60 micrograms a day it prevents heart
disease dementia things like Ms
cataracts and prevents liver cirrhosis
prevents cardio cardiac of the heart
disease prevents cancer prevents certain
types of anemia prevents certain types
of vascular disease certain types of
arthritis certainly can some types of
thyroid problems are all due to a sodium
deficiency and so am I going to risk you
know eating just well and hoping it's in
there's just like Brazil nuts there is a
myth out there that you can eat three
Brazil nuts a day and get all the Selena
Brazil nuts don't require selenium right
okay now if that Brazil nut tree was
grown and so all rich and selenium it'll
have some selenium in there but you
can't tell by looking at that Brazil nut
to see if there's any in there because
it doesn't require it on the other hand
if you look at a tree or a tomato plant
that requires magnesium to make the
green leaves and the chlorophyll so they
can use the sun's energy for growth and
production of whatever it is it's
producing seeds for the Next Generation
if it doesn't have magnesium the leaves
turn yellow once you see brown or yellow
leaves on a plant you know there's not
enough magnesium in there so if there's
minimum magnesium the the plant will
pump that magnesium from the lower
leaves into the growth leaves at the top
and so that's why the the growth leaves
at the top are always green in the lower
leaves are the ones that turn brown
because the plant is stealing from the
lower leaves to give to the growth
leaves and so the same thing is true for
us you get diseases when you're
deficient in these nutrients plants only
need three magnesium phosphorus
potassium so if you're eating a pretty
good slice of organically grown
multigrain bread baked With Love by the
pastor's wife who's a vegan you're 57
short absolutely let's look back at what
you just mentioned about the calcium
back up to the calcium and continue with
the protein piece it's said that protein
consumption causes calcium loss let's
talk about that a little bit well that's
true because protein always has
phosphorus associated with it and the
more phosphorus you increase in your
diet the more calcium you need to be
taking in a ratio of two calcium atoms
per one atom of phosphorus if you're
eating lots of proteins you're getting
lots of phosphorus lots of phosphates
and that increases your your amount of
calcium you have let's say you take in
100 grams of phosphorus a day in a pound
of meat well that means you need four
pound tons of meat if there's calcium in
it or at least the equivalent of four
times that much calcium to make it right
okay and so if you if you look in my
book rare earth wind cures in chapter 11
under calcium I show you the different
types of Fuji and the common average
amounts of phosphorus and calcium in
them and how much you have to supplement
to make up that difference well in the
animal industry we've spent 100 billion
dollars figuring that out just for
calcium dirt okay 100 billion dollars
and so when you look at a guinea pig
pellet you know a little Alfalfa pellet
for guinea pigs a rabbit pellet chicken
pellet duck pellet turkey pellet Mouse
pellet um you have Kibbles and Bits dog
food we've perfected it and anything
that's in that dog food or rabbit food
or guinea pig food or rat food or Mouse
food or chicken food anything that's
actually in the food from a nutritional
standpoint whether it's protein or
whether it's minerals or vitamins is
value added we do not depend on it or
the vegan because they're eating well it
tastes good looks good to the eye eating
well you know fits their philosophy
there are going to get nailed just out
of dumb chance just dumb chance it's
impossible to get everything you need
just by eating well and so they will get
them eventually yeah so let's look at
the the vegetarian philosophy in terms
of there are certain Nutri certain foods
that supposedly provide you with lots of
calcium things like green leafy
vegetables soy sea vegetables molasses
and almonds and figs are all supposedly
great sources of calcium what would you
say to a vegetarian that's trying to eat
that way I would still supplement with
calcium in the day you got from those
fruits and vegetables I would look at
that as value added
I can't stress that enough that you know
human beings are supposedly at the top
end of the intelligence rank compared to
other animals other vertebrates and you
can supplement we actually have
supplement programs and vegans use
there's no animal products in there and
it's insane why would you throw away 50
years of your life because you don't
want a supplement to prove a point it's
impossible it's impossible even these
cultures that live in the world that um
RV and they do eat vegan diet because
they're poor they don't have lands to
graze animals and have animals they
don't live near a sea or they can get
fish and just by necessity or just by
bad luck or where they chose to live or
where they were driven by their enemies
they learned to exist on a vegan diet
well many many peoples and animals have
disappeared you know the species that
didn't make it or the cultures that
didn't make it they disappeared but by
dumb luck by just dumb luck Dirk there's
the top 20 cultures on Earth the top
longevity cultures on Earth they live in
places that have more than 16 minerals
or so and they burn the wood for fuel
for cooking and heating they put those
minerals those AKA wood ashes into their
Gardens their tomatoes and sweet
potatoes and beets and rice and whatever
it is they're growing fruit trees and
and so forth onions suck all those 60 70
minerals up that's what makes us
different our mineral Source our plant
minerals are based from Plants it's an
ancient compost pile contains 77
minerals including all 60 essential
minerals so we're different in that we
provide and guarantee all 60 essential
minerals where nobody else can do that
and so it makes this different you look
at baby food this is very scary this
just came out in in April of 2012. baby
foods that we entrusted our babies to
over the years Similac Enfamil Gerbers
have 13 or less minerals in it now we
need 60. you take a baby and you feed
them a baby formula well the 30 teen
minerals in it how many minerals are in
there 13 13. what about the other 47.
baby doesn't have you wonder why the
baby's screwed up well the babies are
screwed up mentally and physically not
because of vaccinations now vaccinations
there are kids who are terribly damaged
by vaccinations but we're looking at
three out of a thousand terrible damage
and you know I wouldn't vaccinate kids
except for when there's a plague going
through there and ten thousand people
are dying an hour then you want to take
your chances and get that vaccination
right that risk is worth it when
everything is going well and people are
practicing good hygiene Plumbing is
working and and you're eating well
you're supplementing properly I wouldn't
vaccinate and you can opt out everybody
can sign that up down for but you can
never not supplement these longevity
cultures do supplement well there you
said they're third world culture they
are ill or they can't read how would
they know about supplementing well by
dumb luck they practice putting wood
ashes AKA plant minerals plant minerals
AKA wood ashes back into the garden and
that seems to have happened in every
culture around the world thousands of
years it survives yes that's it's the
caveat here and every continent on Earth
these surviving cultures all put wood
ashes into their Garden they are
pregnant women would eat wood ashes they
had these terrible Cravings they would
eat wood ashes during their pregnancy
and these are where the minerals come
from now what happened at three o'clock
in the afternoon Monday September 4th
1882 electricity you got it Thomas
Edison pulled the switch on the first
commercial electric generating plant on
Pearl Street in New York City and the
bluff overlooking the construction of
the Brooklyn Bridge every time I go to
New York I visit that site because that
is the thing that killed millions of
people because how many wood ashes how
many plant minerals do you have left
over how much powder you have left over
to put in your garden when you burn
electricity for fuel zero zero what
about propane or natural gas zero what
about solar energy zero oh my goodness
green can be bad unless you supplement
you got a supplement then you're not
throwing your life away based on the
throw of a dice every morning I mean why
would you do that to your kids why would
you do that to your loved ones why would
you do that to yourself I mean just
think about it if Steve Jobs if Linda
McCartney and Michael Jackson would have
supplemented with minerals Michael
Jackson Steve Jobs and Linda McCartney
all be still alive today oh fantastic
it's unfortunate that it didn't let me
ask you a question how much protein do
you recommend we eat per day well just
for maintenance a 150 pound person
requires 45 grams of pure protein well
to get 45 grams of pure protein like you
get in a laboratory setting you might
have to eat two pounds of protein you
know in this gross form as of beans and
meat and eggs and that kind of stuff to
get enough protein in the proper ratios
and so forth and so I like to err on the
side of excess I I for instance this
morning I had four Poached Eggs okay I
had two ounces of yogurt Cherry yogurt
and I had coffee with my chocolate added
to it so I had my Mocha Cafe the
flavonols the lower blood pressure and
give me some antioxidant points some
auric points oh I had nuts and I had
grapefruits okay I have to replace all
my supplements so how many grams of
protein would you say that you have well
in in an egg and protein there's I think
there's 27 grams of protein per egg okay
so I got over 100 grams of protein which
is about double what they recommend okay
very high quality protein when you look
at the biological value of protein eggs
is 100 red meat is 65 Dairy is 85 so it
goes 100 for eggs 85 for dairy 65 for
red meat you get down to in the 50s 52
to 55 for beans and it's in the 40s 42
to 45 for grain as a biological value in
other words that you can absorb them as
a human being and employ them into
rebuilding your own protein so if you
have a granny who's say 75 years old and
she's losing muscle mass because her
digestion isn't real good are you gonna
give her a vegan diet and give her beans
and protein you know beans and grain are
you going to give her eggs probably eggs
probably she's eating them anyway
that's why she's 75 right yeah she
should be getting egg protein because of
high biological value now here's the
thing that I I get from you know really
well-meaning people Dirk they say well
come on well like look at a cow you get
a thousand pound dairy cow like a whole
steam cow she weighs a thousand pounds
did she eat meat no did she eat eggs
well no uh did she eat fish or or
chicken no why do I need this she's
living on grass out there she grew to be
a thousand pounds well two things
happened there number one she has four
stomachs got 100 million friends and
that one called a rumen those 100
million friends are able to digest fiber
and turn it into amino acids fibers just
a string of carbon put those little bugs
in there some animals some of them plant
material will take nitrogen and put it
onto the carbon chains and turn them
into amino acids and then you're able to
add sulfur to that in your body and turn
it into insulin okay now cow does all
that by just eating grass and green
plants growing on the soil goats can do
it by eating 2 eggs and they browsy pigs
and bushes and things where cows don't
it's all the same thing goats have four
stomachs if you look at all the kind of
six I think it sinks continents on earth
um that have animal life on it the most
universal form of animal life all over
the world is a room in his four stomach
animal why in the old days in the
exploration days in the in the settling
days of America here in North America do
they use oxen to pull wagons instead of
horses because they eat grass because
they ate grass and they could live on
and do very well thank you on the
prairie grasses and didn't need you
didn't need to bring a separate wagon
the whole feed horses or a single
stomach animal like you and me and they
can't eat the same thing as cattle can
and so they had to bring an extra wagon
full of grains for the horsepower and so
that's why they use oxen because oxygen
live off the land but horses you had to
carry their food with well that leads me
to another question I have for you is it
true that all foods have protein and
what's the difference between animal and
vegetable protein you gave us an example
of protein values but what's the
difference between the two types of
proteins and do all foods have protein
um all foods do not have protein okay
there's no protein in honey uh there's
no there's no but if you look at
something like an apple there's not much
protein in an apple unless you eat the
seeds the Protein that's in an apple is
in the seed and when you look at a red
delicious apple what is the weight of
the seeds you know the two dozen seeds
that might be in that Apple it's not
even one percent of the weight of that
app they're very tiny little seeds to
make an apple there's extremely small
amounts of protein in that fruit uh the
more concentrated forms of protein are
in our grains and in seeds and also
beans legumes beans peas lentils things
of this nature also in peanuts which can
be problematic because of the aflatoxins
which is a byproduct of aspergillus
infestation you know fungus infestation
because liver Camp liver disease liver
cirrhosis so that's a negative there
getting protein from peanuts and I hear
that all the time because I travel
around this country I give 300 free
lectures or I meet people you know of
every religion I meet people of who have
different food allergies I meet people
have different dietary beliefs and so I
see people who eat everything you can
think of and there's the universal thing
is the universal shortages are minerals
proteins everybody can kind of get along
they your body has a great capacity to
take amino acids produced by just about
anything and turn it into protein and so
usually vegans have to eat quite a bit
during the day the great volumes of food
as well as eat maybe four or five six
seven meals a day they're constantly
grazing during the day if you want to
use that term in the same like thing
like a cow there's so little food value
in grass that cow is eating all day
constantly that's her job is just to eat
all day and hopefully get and there's a
lot of places on Earth where animals
don't grow there's no animal because
there's no nutrition in the soil so if
you want to grow animals there just
because there's grass the grass only
needs three minerals right counties and
so you're gonna have to supplement this
is one terrible study that I did in
kishan China in kishan China there's no
selenium in the soil and kishan China
there's no selenium in the soil they
have the highest rate of hypertrophy
cardio heart attacks in kids of anywhere
in the world my wife and I went there
and over six week period we did 1200
autopsies and kids below the age of 10
who died of hypertrophic cardiomatically
heart disease was asleep the fish and
they're all poor subsistence Farmers
they didn't have enough animals to to
provide cheese or meat for these kids
chickens couldn't live several many of
them and so they just lived on grain and
vegetables they could grow in the garden
they grew vegetables and grain these
kids would die of hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy heart disease so we
showed them how to supplement with
selenium in a multiple and we wiped that
disease out in those communities but
they have to supplement fantastic that's
an extreme case but it's you know it's
an illustration what's happening on a
lower level in industrialized Nation
because for instance a omnivore somebody
who eats Dairy and meat and eggs and
fish and so forth they're going to get a
little bit of something especially if
they're eating animal products because
animals are supplemented right so
they're going to get a little bit of
something and you wonder why the the
people who when you look at the
long-lived people on Earth at top top 20
longevity cultures my wife and I wrote a
book called immortality where we looked
at that that was a question we looked at
who lives along us because we were
bombarded by people saying my diet's the
best my diet's the best my does so we
looked at these top 20 longevity
cultures and we didn't pick them the the
National Geographic victim we gleaned
through 60 years of National Geographic
and they actually had special issues on
these top 20 longevity cultures and I
was always amazed that they never put
them all in one issue and so we put all
these cultures into one issue
um one one magazine one giant book
actually called immortality we should we
actually over 10 years through the
National Geographic through the
universities in the countries in which
these people live we looked at the soil
analyzes where these people lived we
looked at anthropology studies on them
what they ate and what their cultures
did and so forth how they got there this
is all in this book by the way
immortality shows you how these
illiterate countries these third world
cultures outlive us and are healthier
than us is by dumb luck by dumb luck
they happen to pick a place either they
were chased there by their enemies or
they picked this place because there's a
lot of game there to eat a lot of
animals to eat wild animals and by dumb
luck they have 60 or more minerals there
and so there's are putting their wood
ashes in the gardens or recycling those
60 minerals some of them have 70 some of
them have 80 minerals and they're
putting them all back in the gardens and
they're eating the plants that suck
these nutrients up but they're
supplementing with those minerals by
putting wood ashes in their Garden it's
an indirect supplementation although a
lot of them do put wood ashes in their
food they don't have flour to thicken
things with and so they will thicken a
lot of like stews and soups with wood
ashes so getting the minerals directly
that way and so they do supplement and
this is something we've missed ever
since we've given up wood is our common
Fuel and maybe people could do a better
job as vegans 100 years ago back if they
by dumb luck living in a place that had
enough minerals in the soil and they
were putting wood ashes in their garden
and consuming wood ashes they could as a
vegan survive and do very well but now
we don't do that so now they have to
supplement so that kind of takes me back
to the whole concept A lot of
vegetarians talk about is uh plant Foods
having amino acids let's talk a little
bit about amino acids and protein
complete protein versus income protein
let's talk about that a little well
again that's the Mantra that vegans talk
about they're talking about proteins
they're always talking about protein we
mix seeds and and beans and Grains to
guarantee the right amount of amino
acids and protein well amino acids are
the building blocks for protein amino
acids are the building block for
proteins proteins are made up of
combinations of amino acids when you
look at a protein as a string of amino
acids and when you begin to digest them
you don't just break them down
immediately into all individual amino
acids they're broken down into Strings
of amino acids short strings from long
strings or short strings these are
called polypeptide okay if you absorb
these polypeptides which most people do
and you have nutritional deficiencies
you can't fend these things off you
become allergic to them your body
recognizes them and wheat or corn or
potato or Pea or the strawberries or
whatever it might be because you're not
digesting these things down to the
individual amino acids before you you
absorb them and this is a great great
research project where they actually
show where you can absorb digestive
enzymes and these the digestive enzymes
they would take them from your blood and
still they worked as an enzyme after
taken from your blood the digestion
process didn't denature the enzyme I
found that very fascinating people get
hung up particularly vegans and
vegetarians of various types over
vegetarians oval lacto vegetarians oval
lacto piscopal vegetarians they get hung
up on the protein thing that's only one
of the 90 essential nutrients group you
need to to go and make sure you're
getting all 90 don't get fixated on the
protein and so is it a challenge though
even say for instance like myself a
person has been using all 90 Central
nutrients and using a protein supplement
is there still challenges for instance
cholesterol is that a challenge for a
vegan okay well protein you can you know
you can eat enough beans and Grains to
get protein now you've introduced a new
word here cholesterol now this is a
different story you have to appreciate
that 85 percent of the weight of every
cell on your body's cholesterol you have
steroid hormones such as testosterone
estrogen progesterone and and adrenal
hormones which are 85 or 90 by weight
cholesterol so your adrenal hormones
testosterone estrogen progesterone are
all steroid hormones and they're 85 to 9
by weight cholesterol so if you're not
eating cholesterol you cannot make
enough you cannot make enough to get all
the hormones you need you cannot make
enough rebuild and maintain your brain
85 percent no 75 75 of your brain weight
is the myel in the white matter of the
brain and 100 of the white matter of the
brain the mild of the brain the
insulation material the brain is
cholesterol and so if you think you're
going to get through life and live a
long healthful life and not be you know
have Dementia or depressed or make
depression and so on um without either
supplementing with cholesterol you know
take a cholesterol Soft gel capsule like
we take fish oil capsules or eating eggs
and fat from meat you're living in la la
land you just can't do it you can't make
enough for your own needs so how much
cholesterol in comparison to how much
does the body make in comparison to what
you need about five percent the body
makes about five percent body makes
about five percent of the cholesterol
that your body needs if you're going to
complete cholesterol free diet you will
not live very long you can't and um if
you I always tell people okay yeah
veganism was the optimal way to live and
I call veganism more of a political diet
as opposed to you know save the Earth
and don't eat animals you can feed 100
people for what you can feed one cow and
so I look at it as a political diet as
opposed to a nutritional diet unless
it's supplement you can do it
supplementary okay so I was comparing uh
we had talked about protein but I said
we can supplement with protein but the
cholesterol piece was that an issue
we're vegans yes okay and so the
cholesterol piece you have to supplement
cholesterol you have to eat cholesterol
every day again when you look at vegans
as a group you take an average lifespan
of vegans you take the average lifespan
of all peoples in the world and you take
an average lifespan of all vegans in the
world the vegans are not going to live
as long as the people who get animal
proteins because attached to animal
proteins is cholesterol I'm going to we
start looking at the rates of emotional
problems with vegan depression mag
depression bipolar disease anxiety
attacks panic attacks I'm going to start
looking at adrenal exhaustion I'm going
to look at things like dementias
Alzheimer's disease infertility
miscarriages and a guarantee is much
higher in vegans as a group than it is
in meat eaters or at least people who
eat animal protein don't have to eat
meat you can eat eggs and fish and that
kind of thing if I had to pick one
animal protein I would pick eggs I would
take eggs because of the cholesterol
associated with it so we talked earlier
about the different types of vegetarians
in the U.S and so is there really any
difference because I know vegetarians
like to differentiate the ones that are
only eating fish think that they're
they're better off by avoiding the red
meat or avoiding the chicken is there
any real difference between the types of
protein including eggs when you're
talking about animal protein again when
you when you look at the biological
value this is well documented the U.S
department culture did this egg protein
100 Dairy protein is 85 red meat is 65.
beans and nuts and there's not much
protein and that's mostly fat but not
cholesterol it's saturated fat beans and
nuts they're protein you're looking at
oh 62 to 65 percent biological value
we're looking at grains it's down to 42
to 45 and so by mixing grains and nuts
and legumes you're better off because
you're raising that biological value up
for yourself and again it's it to me
it's a political statement more than a
nutritional a viable nutritional thing
because can you find me any colonies of
vegans Dirk where they weaned the baby
off the mother's breast milk and say a
year old two years old four years old
doesn't matter they wean the baby off
the mother's breast milk and they went
immediately to a vegan diets and there's
hundreds of kids happy giggly kids
running around well more I think more
what you're talking about in terms of
political and religious organizations
that become vegetarian or vegan because
of those reasons I don't know if any
other coaches otherwise but I was more
addressing sometimes people want to
think that their type of vegetarianism
for instance a lacto or a oval or Pesco
might think that it's better for them to
eat this way is significantly no
difference there's really no true again
eight protein and dairy protein are much
higher okay in the biological value
system but they're still eating animal
protein that's right yeah well and it's
still and and the reason I bring that up
is because typically people are so
afraid of cholesterol and no matter what
animal protein you're eating you're
getting cholesterol and so uh the value
you're saying egg is the best and then I
think it was uh chicken was before was
was better than than red meat and so
forth and so on but uh I was just trying
to make a point in terms of uh you're
still getting Pro you're still eating
animal protein you're still eating
cholesterol and there are some values
that are higher in some of the proteins
but you're still eating animal protein
so you're you're not really a vegetarian
in other words yeah your omnivore you're
a person that eats animal and vegetables
yeah and so people who are not vegans
are really omnivores as opposed to
vegetarian absolutely okay let's move on
let's talk a little bit about energy
from a meat Source versus a vegetable
Source what's the difference there well
depending on what vegetable if you're
getting energy from lettuce you have to
work real hard to get if you get energy
from a potato
it costs you four times more in terms of
B vitamins than it does if you're
getting energy from meat red meat
because protein and fats are cheaper to
burn in terms of cofact as opposed to
carbohydrates carbohydrates are very
expensive to burn from terms of cofact
and so the worst thing we do in the
world Dirk is when you have these
famines you have these disasters around
the world natural disasters and famines
we think grain we send rice right rice
we send we send them white rice and
we're sending them plane loads and
boatloads and truckloads of white rice
and then they all die they all get berry
berry and they all get pellegra and they
all die congestive heart fire and
kwashiorkor and all this kind of stuff
we'd be much better off to give them the
90 essential nutrients and a protein bar
and with bags of a rice and again this
is all from advice being given to them
by Consulting doctors to the UN and to
governments all over the world people's
diet is primarily eating rice so let's
send them rice no they're eating chicken
eggs they're eating fish and they're
eating monkeys that they catch they're
eating you know they're birds and
they're eating goat meat and cheese and
milk and everything you know even the
Maasai they live on cattle blood and
milk and you know you look at them and
man they're seven foot tall they're very
healthy people and they live on milk and
blood and the secret though is they live
in places that have lots of minerals in
the soil and so the sweet potatoes and
things like that that they do eat depoy
and stuff that they
um are grown and soil that they're
putting their wood ashes back in there
they happen to live in places that have
lots of minerals and so it's more than
the superficial look and people tend to
not having the other knowledge they
don't know what questions they ask so
they say they visit there and they say
well these people are I mean they're
living on Rice you look at the Chinese
they're living on Rice well yeah but the
Chinese eat more animal protein per
person I think there was a book out
called The China Study and he said
everybody in China is a vegetarian of
some type or vegan well the only vegans
and vegetarians in China are American
visitors who are vegans well what about
Buddhists there are a lot of Buddhists
that are vegetarians also ah they're
vegetarians are not vegans they will
drink milk and cheese and stuff like
that yeah so they'll do that so they're
a lacto oval philosophy as opposed to
being vegan
um and I remember back in the 60s and
70s when uh athletes for instance or on
a high protein diet and then late 70s
and 80s moved to a high carb diet that
philosophy who's better off doing that
in the Long Haul the ones who are eating
a high protein diet were better are
often the ones that ate a high carb diet
remember carbohydrates are more
expensive in terms of cofactors needed
to get the energy extracted from as
opposed to protein and when you look at
some of the crazy things professional
athletes do you know jump in the stands
and beat up paying customers and
they do crazy things they can't control
themselves and that's because they lose
these nutrients so fast because they've
carved up they carve up carb up carb up
the night before that was actually
invented by the wife of a Canadian his
name was Brian Maxwell he had Run 100
marathons he had 14 gold medals running
the marathon and his wife invented the
the power bar and went for the carbs and
she invented the the carb up the night
before and that way you had more energy
to run your race because they were
looking at the glycogen the animal
starch stored in your liver and muscles
and so forth and
um it was just one of those terrible
things they created because what happens
is when you carve up you're gonna have
energy for a while and then you crash
and you go into the state of depression
you go into a state of depression after
a while because your blood sugar is
dropping like a rock and this doesn't
happen when you eat protein because when
you have protein mixed with fat it
stabilizes your blood sugar and now
they've gone back to eating you know a
steak the night before and eggs for
breakfast before a big event whether
it's football or basketball or soccer or
run yeah I was a college basketball
player and I remember doing those mid
70s mid to late 70s we would eat steak
and eggs for pre-game meals and that was
pretty much the standard bad thing and
you'd stabilize your blood sugar and
you'd have enough nutrients to to
perform at a very high heaven the ones
who still practice carving up the night
before will crash somewhere in the
middle of the game okay well let's talk
a little bit about some of the positive
is about being a vegetarian uh for
instance the high antioxidant levels
which will increase your immune system
high fiber high water and even the 1970s
work done by Dr Dean ornish in terms of
clearing the arteries of some of his
patients using a vegetarian diet let's
address some of the positives I guess
and to what degree they are positive for
sure um there are positives to vegan
diet but again you can't let those
positives blind you thank you aligned
you to ignoring the negatives right yeah
what you want to do is get the positives
from the vegan diet and supplement and
make up the deficiencies of the
negatives and you're fine and um you
know I find people like yourself who've
been a vegan for at least 20 years that
I know of and you're extremely well you
do your Martial Arts your martial arts
master and I'm so very proud of you that
you supplement heavily
um and you're an example of what a vegan
can be you're as fit and tough
physically as a vegan can be and you've
been very faithful to a vegan diet I
know this I've known you for 15 years
but you supplement properly and you make
up the deficiencies and so whatever you
get from your food is value added now
one of the things we have learned about
eating more vegetables and fruits and
things of that nature is that the
antioxidants will help fend off certain
diseases you can reduce your risk of
cardiovascular disease you can reduce
your risk of dementias you can reduce
your risk of cataracts you can reduce
your risk of cancer by getting your orac
points or antioxidant points above 100
000 orac points a day and orac points is
an acronym that was coined by the US
Department of Agriculture called oxygen
radical absorption capacity it's a
measurement of how many free radicals
are actually neutralized by the
antioxidants in the food and of course
antioxidants come in many forms let's
just look at the one that's produced by
the body the most potent one produced by
the body is called glutathione this is
one of the most potent antioxidants out
there but if you don't have enough
selenium one of the things that happens
is one molecule of glutathione will
knock off one molecule of a free radical
and it's done generous more there's
supplementing with selenium in proper
amounts that selenium will recycle that
one molecule of glutathione so it might
work against one molecular glutathione
in the presence of sicilium might knock
off a thousand
molecules of a free radical wow that's
amazing yeah and so you can't just think
in terms of the antioxidants you get
either from the food or is produced by
your body when you're eating that food
and so you do have to bring in all the
support cofactors to guarantee it's all
going to work properly so auric points
is a way of measuring that and of course
um one of the things we know result in
anti-aging effects are the antioxidants
you find in dark berries including
grapes black grapes and purple and blue
grapes have more antioxidants than green
grapes you look at something as simple
as Resveratrol which is the stuff that
is given credit for the French Living 10
years longer than us they say well it's
the French paradox they live 10 years
longer than us because they wean their
babies off of breast milk onto wine they
don't even drink water right and
Resveratrol so I like to take in the
equivalent of about 900 glasses of red
wine a day in terms of Resveratrol
supplementation and so I'm getting the
antioxidant power of 900 glasses of red
wine a day as opposed to drinking 900 as
a red wine of course you wouldn't get
that before he'd be unconscious of all
the alcohol but my understanding too is
uh even even eating a very good
vegetarian diet I understand one serving
of a fruit or vegetable will only give
you about 600 auric points compared to a
supplement program where you can take as
you said anywhere from 50 to 100 000
very easily per day yes so the challenge
is even if you are a super duper
vegetarian and you ate uh 20 servings of
fruits and vegetables per day which most
people won't do you would never get past
ten thousand twelve thousand auric
points yes and that's sufficient to help
fight off disease you're exactly right
and of course you've taken what would
you say 200 servings of fruits no no I
said 20. yeah you're going to get
screaming diarrhea with all that fiber
and fruits and vegetables right and so I
like dark chocolate so we have a lot of
dark chocolate products and dark
chocolate is a wonderful way to get orac
points and you can take a good quality
dark chocolate liquid that has three
thousand Oak points per ounce we have a
piece of chocolate the size of a pad of
butter you take two of those little
pieces of dark chocolate that
um have or the size of a pad of butter
have the amount of antioxidants in it
that you get in 25 servings of fruits
and vegetables it'll give you 33 000
auric points eat two pieces of this
chocolate and it's vegetarian friendly
oh it is it's vegan it's vegan friendly
okay it's vegan friendly plus it has a
flavon oils to help lower blood pressure
it's just they're wonderful things and
of course all vegans should be using are
dark chocolate because you can you can
take I take six pieces a day so I'm
getting over a hundred thousand points a
day and so whatever you get from your
food is value-added now you got it that
that's the secret to making this work
whether you're a vegan a vegetarian
whether you're an oval lacto vegetarian
whether you're a meat eater whether
you're a meat and potatoes kind of guy
if you supplement you're leveling the
playing field so no matter what your
dietary choices are whatever value you
get from your food is value added you
know you look at a medical doctor who
gets less than 30 minutes of nutritional
training in 14 years of medical school
and residency an internship these guys
say well eat lots of variety and put
four different colors on your plate
that's insane when we spent 100 billion
dollars tripling the lifespan of dogs
eliminating 900 different diseases and
still plague humans by making sure they
had all the nutrients in their food yeah
and the science is there and too often I
find in Natural Health that people will
approach me and say uh where'd you get
that from I don't believe it my doctor
never told me that well
their science is there you just haven't
read it and I always tell people also
you don't ride in a horse and buggy
anymore you drive a car I personally
don't wash my dishes by hand I put in a
dishwasher I mean if the science is
there use it and certainly the science
is there that nutritional
supplementation is so important and it's
such a struggle to get people to
understand that well all you have to do
is look at the lifespan of a doctor even
a vegan doctor the average lifespan is
56. why would you go to a group of guys
and gals whose average lifespan is 56 to
learn how to live be 100 in health away
they're not the go-to people as one of
my colleagues Dr Glidden always says God
bless her little hearts she's loving the
pieces but it should be a felony for
them to give advice when it comes to
nutrition they just their patients in
this service whenever they give them
advice about nutrition Let's uh let's
talk a little bit about some of the
negatives about vegetarianism for
instance those that have a high starch
high carb diet talk a little bit about
B12 deficiency and also like to discuss
some of the conditions that may arise
from pregnant women sure children okay
young teens all of those sort of things
let's start out on the front end here
let's start out with conception most of
the infertility problems that occur in
the world are caused by malnutrition and
I see a lot of people many of whom are
vegans who are infertile they just can't
get pregnant how do I get pregnant well
how many aging well no I'm a vegan well
there you go and so I said well I want
you to eat you know say 130 to 150 pound
woman I say I want to eat four eggs
every day I can't do that well you're
not gonna get pregnant oh you ever have
miscarriage I've had four miscules that
means you're not it's Cheryl because you
can get pregnant you just can't hold the
pregnancy what do you supplement well
I'm a purist I just eat very well and I
I get everything I need for my food well
no let's say you have a pregnancy in an
unsupplemented vegan the odds of you
having a baby that has some biochemical
or physical problems can be very high
cleft palate spina bifida neural tube
defects uh things like heart defects of
all kinds cerebral palsy Down syndrome
is very high cystic fibrosis mustard
dystrophy what I find is dirt and I work
with large colonies of certain cultures
that you know as much as 30 to 50
percent of the births in those cultures
are cystic fibrosis and moisture the men
died average age of 62 it cardiomyopathy
heart disease all which is a slame
deficiency and so it's imperative when
you know these things in a community and
not to supplement just keep going to
fertility clinics hoping that this
pregnancy be the good one I'm paying
thousands 25 000 for in vitro
fertilization artificial insemination
and they're getting pregnant naturally
sexual intercourse they just can't hold
the pregnancy because they don't have
enough nutrition to hold the pregnancy
so I get more women pregnant than any
other man in history I get about 25
000. I mean the only one that I can't
keep up with is the history of Solomon
right he had 300 wives could I get about
25 000 women pregnant every year but
it's always from nutrition regulating
what they eat eliminating gluten adding
the 90 essential nutrients and then you
can eat whatever diet you want so what
about some of the deficiency conditions
like B12 iron deficiency anemia tell me
a little bit about that well these are
very common in people who are vegans
again both of those are nutrient
deficiencies right right
um and vitamin B12 is sort of a weird
vitamin and then it has a mineral
attached to it Cobalt okay and so when
you're deficient in B12 several things
can be happening number one you might
supplement with B12 and still be
deficient B12 if you don't have enough
stomach acid well how much salt do you
well none my doctor told me to cut back
on my soul so I just get enough for my
food really and you have a B12
deficiency well yeah so I have to take
B12 shot because I've tried
supplementation won't work well that's
because you're not making enough stomach
acid because you require salt sodium
chloride to make stomach and so even if
you supplement with B12 and you're not
making stomach acid you can't absorb it
because there's a factor produced by the
stomach called intrinsic factor I guess
the whole name is Castle's intrinsic
factor and it binds with Von B12 in the
presence of stomach acid to be absorbed
minerals can't particularly iron can't
since you brought that up iron
specifically has to be absorbed in an
acid environment if you're drinking and
I sell alcohol water I love alkaline
water but not during meals because it
neutralizes your stomach acid and you
won't be able to absorb nutrients
efficiently I see an enormous number of
people who are very very ill with maybe
20 diseases because it can't absorb
nutrients they're drinking structured
alkaline water with meal so we have all
kinds of problems going on here that
affect what goes on in your stomach and
even if you supplement you could be
deficient in these things iron is very
tricky B12 is very tricky digesting
proteins is very tricky even if you're
eating good protein regardless of the
source and you're not making stomach
acid then pepsin the enzyme produced by
the stomach to digest protein down into
the amino acids which are then easily
absorbed and don't cause allergies
you'll wind up absorbing polypeptides
because you don't have enough stomach
acid for the pepsin to work properly I
find it interesting people always want
to say well cooking microwaves destroys
the enzymes of my food well you don't
need enzymes in your food because you
produce all the enzymes you need if
you're getting a perfect diet oh that's
a great lead-in dot live foodists or raw
foodist concept because too often
they're purest in their philosophy that
I'm not going to cook anything I'm not
going to raise the temperature above 117
degrees I'm going to get all the enzymes
and get all these great things you just
share with us the body will make enzymes
if you're healthy and another point that
I want to make on that same note those
people are typically very health
conscious people like most vegetarians
they're trying to be healthy but
unfortunately they only have bits and
pieces of information they don't have
enough information to complete the
circle they're they're in trouble
unfortunately exactly right and it's the
pieces that are left out that cause the
problem cook improperly when you eat
improperly when you supplement
improperly you're going to have problems
and because vegans tend to be very
strict and and you know there's
breathitarians and there's raw foodists
and and so forth and most people can't
handle raw food diet because there are
phytates and raw vegetables and Grains
whole grains phytates are the things
that make a carrot pop when you break it
in half it snaps if I taste or what
makes Hull or the bran on wheat Hard and
shiny um it's the thing that makes the
seeds on the PODS of a pea snap when you
when you break it and these phytates
bind onto your dietary minerals into an
indigen indigestible unabsorbable
compound which goes out the other end in
the toilet they're going to even be very
well and the more raw foods you eat the
more you're in danger from phytates
again in chapter 11 of that book Rare
Earth has been cures I have a whole big
section in that chapter 11 on phytates
and the hazard of eating raw foods uh
constantly with breakfast lunch and
dinner you're going to be in trouble
especially if you don't supplement I
think they most of the raw Foodies are
typically marinating their foods and so
they're not actually eating it in its
rice I guess if you is that if that's a
word Roy state they're doing some sort
of marinating and some and eliminating
that pop or snap that you're talking
about uh but the enzyme piece is not
factual is it dot no you don't need
enzymes from your food you make all the
ends of Digestive and absorption enzymes
you need to make all this in fact that's
what DNA and RNA do is they make enzymes
because we are enzyme beings you can't
use oxygen without enzymes you can't use
food without enzymes you can't create
energy or burn energy without enzyme and
so you've been provided with all that
you need in your body you don't need to
be eating it but you do need to eat the
raw materials and the cofactor is
necessary for those enzymes to work okay
well let me ask you one more thing
um one of the I guess uh prideful things
that vegetarians talk about is having a
low-fat diet what's the challenge with
having a low-fat diet diet vegetarians
okay there's two problems with a low fat
diet number one we are a fat eating
organism human beings are we require fat
in fact as much as 60 to 70 percent of
your calories should come from fat you
know medical doctors say less than 30
they want you down 26 24 of your
calories coming from fat really we
should be having 60 to 70 percent of
your calories coming from fat number one
the stabilize your blood sugar
um and you don't get obese when you eat
fat when you think about that when they
fatten cattle for Ruth Chris's
Steakhouse to make them Prime Beef right
or you go to the Hilton in New York City
and you want a Prime Steak I mean you
want two inches of fat on you want all
that beautiful marbling in the middle
it's so tender you can cut it with a
fork do they feed those cattle fat or
whole grains whole grain oink
the reason why we're the number one
obese nation in the world is because
we've been told to eat whole grains now
eating whole grains in the absence of
minerals you will get fat you will
develop diabetes and so that's very
problematic whole fat is good for you
chicken fat not fried roasted raw baked
is good that's for the French you think
that a 5 star French chef is going to
bake a croissant for the president of
France using canola oil and margarine no
he's going to use eggs and cream and
butter and lard absolutely and they live
10 years longer than us all right also
you have the essential fatty acids right
you need Omega-3s sixes and nines but
your fats whether it's plant fats or
animal fats some
um sources of these fats like plant have
maybe eight percent some oils have only
eight percent essential fatty acids like
olive oil is nice eight to twelve
percent uh Omega-3s you look at um
flaxseed oil 78 you look at porridge
Aboriginal is very high primrose oil and
primrose oil is very high of 78 but also
when you look at fish oil you look at a
very high Salmon Oil 78 omega-3 so
there's certain plant oils that are the
same as fish oils but there's certain
plants that are very very low and you
couldn't eat enough to get what you need
we use fat very efficiently for energy
it doesn't cost you a lot of cofactors
so it's cheaper to burn fat for fuel in
terms of cofactors than it is to burn
carbohydrate fat is very important to
human beings we eat we should be eating
60 to 70 percent of our calories coming
from fat and by chance then you're going
to get more of the essential fatty acids
but depending on what the analyte for
instance if you eat a deer and eat the
fat from the deer or eat the fat from
chicken has been fed beans a lot of
beans and they're they're going to have
more Omega-3s in it than if they're just
fed wheat only okay and and
um you need fat too again for energy we
need it to make our brains and we need
the cholesterol that's in fat to make
steroid hormones testosterone estrogen
progesterone adrenal hormones so people
who are on a strict fat-free diet are
not going to make okay and last part
that I like to discuss with you doc many
times vegetarians will pose certain
questions about meat and why we
shouldn't eat it for instance there are
pharmaceutical drugs and meat
antibiotics hormones pesticide residue
then talk they also talk about processed
means the dangers of cancer carcinogenic
effect process meets parasites bacteria
high levels of adrenal hormones and
animal flesh let's talk about that a
little bit the the bad part that
vegetarians talk about in terms of meat
eating well certainly they're quite
correct I give them they're quite
correct when it comes to processed Meats
with nitrates and nitrites and it does
increase your risk of cancer increase
your risk of cardiovascular disease
particularly arterial sclerosis
anthosclerosis because elevated blood
cholesterol triglycerides do not cause
coronary heart disease or any vascular
disease elevated blood cholesterol are
triglycerides do not cause stroke
our high blood pressure our
cardiovascular disease or plugging of
the arteries Coronas thrombosis
pulmonary emulatives and deep vein
thrombosis it has nothing to do with
cholesterol and um it has nothing to do
with triglycerides it has everything to
do with eating things like processed
Meats with nitrates and nitrites eating
fried foods even eating stir-fried foods
of organically grown vegetables with
extra extra virgin virgin olive oil
that's why in 1971 when I just did that
study comparing the coronary arteries
blockages from vegans during meteors the
vegans had the worst plugged arteries
and
um the the thing you have to appreciate
from again the fat and the cholesterol
is that these are essential nutrients
and we must have them you have to get
them somewhere you can't make enough
high fat diets are useful for us we for
instance I can take people with the
Parkinson's disease and give them the 90
essential nutrients in a couple of what
we call our secret sauces and give them
12 to 15 eggs a day and I can I can
eliminate all Parkinson's symptoms in
three months people who have dementia
been diagnosed with Alzheimer's Disease
by four very well respected neurologists
and including the head of the Department
of Neurology to medical school diagnosed
this guy with Alzheimer's disease in one
week's time they declared him cured on
my program that's great because he had
to eat 12 eggs a day right because it
was replacing his brain plus the 90
essential nutrients and I do this
literally thousands of times a year
fixing people with these neurological
problems adrenal exhaustion is a
cholesterol deficiency disease is a fat
deficiency disease and I I know I see so
many people with adrenal exhaustion when
you go to these health fairs and trade
shows people who try to eat right
they're doing their best or their
heart's in the right place or trying to
eat right I have no disrespect for them
from that place but and I always tell
them if you want to be a vegan you can
be a successful vegan like my good
friend here Dirk twine if you just
supplement properly you can do it and so
if being a vegan is that important to
you you need to supplement do it
correctly and you'll you'll be fine but
if you don't supplement your your every
morning you're waking up playing that
game throwing those Dice and if he you
know Snake Eyes comes up absolutely so
basically doc the the point that I tried
to make initially was the vegan is the
one that is in the greatest Danger
that's correct the other forms of
vegetarianism you're getting a lot that
the body need peace that the vegan is
missing is particularly the cholesterol
piece and the fat pieces and the
minerals and the mineral piece but all
all types need the 90 Central nutrients
the 60 minerals the 16 vitamins the 12
amino acids The Three fatty acids
everybody needs that every living
breathing walking human being and all
vertebrates hummingbirds elephants
snakes other fish all need it okay and
so with the essential nutrients the
other types other than the vegan type
they're in very good condition if it
gets shape if they're supplemented with
all 90s
all 90 essential nutrients they're in
good shape but the vegan even with
supplementation there's some challenges
that we have to be aware of that's right
so it's very important that we know this
and understand this and I and I and for
me personally I became a vegan as I
searched for healthy eating ways I
didn't become a vegan for any other
reason other than seeking good health
and so as we learn more we should do
more and so I think it's very important
and I wanted to share that information I
want to thank you again doc because as I
said I've been a vegan for almost 20
years I feel compelled to share this
information with others so that they can
be healthy and live a long healthy life
and and I really appreciate all the work
that you've done and you're far from
being a vegetarian and sharing this
information so that the vegetarian
community and the uh and vegetarian
family can can live long healthy lives
all Americans can live long healthy
lives all people of the world with this
information can live long healthy lives
you're exactly right now there's no
reason why everybody can't live to be
well beyond 100 a human being has a
capacity to live long well beyond a
hundred the fact that we don't has
nothing to do with genetics it has to do
with nutritional deficiencies I always
tell people if you're not prepared to
supplement properly what you're saying
is there's too much bother for you to
take supplements and kind of understand
why you need to take them and pass it on
your children it's it's more important
to just forget that stuff because it's
too much problem for you to deal with it
than having 50 more years with your
grandkids because if you supplement
properly you're going to get 50 more
years of your grandkids is it and to me
that's worth everything I pluck my eyes
out and cut my arms off for 50 more
years of my grandkids right and so just
changing my dad a little bit and
supplementing that's a small price to
pay for 50 more years with their
grandkids absolutely thank you very much
God bless your dirt keep up the great
heart thank you this CD is not intended
to diagnose prescribe or treat any
diseases it is your responsibility to
consult your personal health care
practitioner prior to beginning any type
of health and wellness program also ask
the person that gave you this CD for
more information about Dr Wallach and
his nutritional products
foreign